It is great to welcome to the program.
Jordan Belfort, who's a former stockbroker
author, motivational speaker, he's author
of [inaudible],
the book the Wolf of wall street.
Ultimately adapted into the blockbuster film
by the same name back in 2013.
Jordan, so great to have you on today.
My pleasure.
What's going on?
So I have so many areas where, where we could
start, but I think maybe one place would be,
you know, I've read your book, I've seen the
movie.
Are you pleased with the way the book was
adapted into the movie and how much of a say
did you have over that?
Um, yeah, I mean obviously I was very pleased,
uh, you know, with you, it's pretty much a
hard to go wrong with Scorsese and DiCaprio,
the wet and Terry winter.
It was a screen writer with that did my book
and I worked very closely with all of them,
especially with, um, with Leo and with Terry
winter.
So I wrote all of the, uh, board room scenes
and the, the language in the motivational
speeches in the sales pitches and all that
stuff that, so it was a really collaborative
experience.
A lot of just a great, you know, um, you know,
great taste in my mouth and it was all over.
And to that man.
I mean like I, I think that the proof speaks
in the audience, like how they responded.
I mean, the mood became like pretty much the
biggest cult hit of all times.
So it's like he's up there, the Rocky horror,
I figure these days that people just, you
know, just watch it again and again and again
and it just keeps expanding.
So it's that I'm very pleased.
And what about in terms of, I mean, when you,
when, when I read your book, there's a lot
more in the book about sort of like your state
of mind as you were going through everything
that you did.
And that can be hard to translate into a movie
that's a couple hours long from a four or
500 page book or however long it was.
It felt very short to be clear, but it was
not a short book.
So what, what about your, your sort of mindset
as you were going through the building of
the firm and everything that happened?
Yeah.
Well, I think that, you know, if there was
one source of frustration with the movie,
it was that, that, you know, yeah, it was
pretty much that, that aspect.
I think that, I think that they, one thing
they missed was the slow, the evolution of
ethics and integrity.
Like I didn't, it was like in the movie, it's
like I go down to wall street, I'm like this
really idealistic young guy and like, can
we make our clients money?
And they're like, no, you can.
And the next scene I'm with at a strip club
snorting Coke right at didn't happen.
And that, that, that I went there as a very
good kid, never got in trouble for, and there
was over a period of years as slowly but surely
one step over that ethical line ate away at
my moral center for that period of time.
You know, before you know what you're doing,
things you thought you'd never do and it seems
perfectly okay.
So I mean, that PO kinda got left out of the
movie.
And, you know, in addition, I think a lot
of the, um, you know, uh, the idea, you know,
of, you know, people say, well, you know,
you felt like almost like there was no guilt
involved.
That's, I mean, every single day I was, you
know, felt terrible.
I was going on and I felt like I was almost
like, you know, an actor on a stage in my
own life.
Uh, and just sort of going through emotions,
that's a very common feeling that, um, a lot
of people were very successful.
And like when things are spiraling out of
control, you almost feel, and it's not true,
it's just a feeling you have.
You start to believe that you can't get off
the revolving, you know, there's like a sort
of, you know, the elevator is going up and
down and you just can't get up and you really
can.
So those things, did it make it into the movie?
And uh, but the good news is the TV series
that's going to be coming out next year, early
next year, late this year, and that will really
delve much deeper into all that stuff.
And also what happened before and after.
So for people who don't know, um, there were
ultimately there was an FBI investigation
that in the book, in with the, with the, uh,
20, 20 hindsight that you have when you were
writing the book, you talk about how long
it had actually been going on and it had been
going on quite a long time until you, you
detail the drug addiction in the book with
all of this stuff.
Can you talk a little bit about how from the
outside it can seem like you say, like from
one day to the next, things are crazy and
you're in completely over your head, but that
in reality it's a little bit at a time that
you take one step and then you take another
small step and then before you know it, you're
sort of in over your head.
Yeah, it's, it's again, it's like we as human
beings, we become desensitized to the same
things that happen again.
And again, I'll give you an example.
The first time I ever had got a subpoena from
an agency, it was the NASB, which is a regulatory
body.
And, um, I think it's called FINRA now, right?
And they sent me the subpoena and I was devastated.
I was like, I was like, Oh my God, I couldn't
sleep for a month.
Right?
Fast forward three years, four years.
I'm like, I got a subpoena from the sec, a
real agency, and I'm like pissing on it.
It's like, fuck you.
You know, it's like, and it's shocking that,
that, that you can get to that point, but
what happens is as the mind work, unless shoe
do that, you'll go crazy.
You have to sort of learn the cubbyhole put
it's a little box and go on.
And that's how you rationalize your life away.
Right?
And that can work in your, your advantage
and also to your disadvantage depending on
the situation to protective mechanisms so
you can continue focusing and moving forward
without going crazy.
Right.
But, uh, it also leads to behaviors that become,
you know, skewed irrationally or massively
two to one to one side of the equation because
you've lost your, the gut check.
You've kind of, you know, the realities that
have been locked away and then just acting
without that.
So,
so when you're in the midst of it, you know,
you said that it w it's not right to portray
the idea that you had no reservations about
what you were doing and that you had no guilt
so to speak.
But when you're in it, what is the sort of
like rationalizing mechanism that happens
where, where you say, well, I'm nine steps
in at this point I'm taking step 10 for example.
Like what, what is going on in your mind
as you continue to get deeper into it?
So you remember that there's a very big difference
to what I did to what someone like a Bernie
Madoff did.
So like plea fraud being born as all fiction,
that in my case, 95% plus of what I was doing
was legal.
So what you end up doing is you focused on
the legal stuff, right?
And then you say what everyone's doing the
other stuff too.
So you, you look to, everyone's doing it,
it's like, Hey, you can't use that augment.
You're a criminal robbing houses, you can't
use that.
But if you're in the area where I was just
like this sort of gray area where like you're
doing most things right and you have this
one little thing that's wrong.
Now in reality that's still illegal, right?
But you're able to then sort of say, well,
it's mostly legal and everyone's doing that
anyway.
I'm just better at it.
And that's sort of the rationalizing process.
So I think that's how a lot of people, um,
like for instance when you have like, um,
a, you see like a wall street guy who's um,
doing 90% of everything, right?
Like what was a big one now Sanjay something
or there was a billion multibillion dollar
hedge fund and the guy got caught doing insider
trading, yet there was a legitimate head turn.
Everything was right.
And probably, you know, if you did a hundred
trades, five Ryan's light information, one
is enough to get you thrown in jail.
Right?
But he's saying to himself, well, everyone's
doing it.
And most of what I do is Lily white.
So, you know, that's how it really, it gets
played out in your own mind.
So I want to get your thoughts on just the
regulation of the financial industry a little
bit, but in order to do that, I'm curious
from reading the book, my sense of you is
that your politics are sort of like socially
do whatever.
You don't really care liberal, libertarian,
but that uneconomic stuff, you might be more
of what we would call like a Mitt Romney type
conservative, so to speak.
Am I way off on that?
Is that roughly your, where your politics
are exactly right?
I mean, I'm, I'm, I'm about as socially liberal
as you can get and about, I wouldn't say I'm
as fiscally conservative.
I'm very fiscally conservative.
Um, I, I strongly believe that Trump is on
the right track economically with the things
he's doing.
Really?
Ah, yeah.
Oh, that's interesting.
I do, I on the social, on the social side
of things, uh, yeah, I'm way I'm as liberal
as you could get.
Like, you know, marry who you want, sleeping
through your wants.
I mean, that's just like, to me it's like
I don't really understand how you can be a
conservative and not be socially liberal if
you really think it through.
It's idiotically ridiculous for you to think
that I want the government out of my life
for my business and my finances.
But we should tell people what they, who they
should marry, who they should sleep with,
what's right, what's wrong, who should do
what they want with their body.
I don't see how you can reconcile those two
with a straight face.
I think that knows, respects a lot of the
message gets hijacked by the religious right.
And uh, and they have a very powerful lobby.
So the Republican party is forced to take
on positions they probably mostly don't believe
in.
Did you, I mean, how could you honestly think
that gay marriage is, is evil?
I mean it's just so stupid.
I mean like people, I agree with you, but
so you're saying you think some of the opposition
is insincere from the right to gay marriage?
Literally.
I'm sure most of them are wishing, praying.
I'm sure Trump is wishing he could say things
about certain he's not.
He's um, he's a Democrat his whole life.
The guy, he was a Democrat, you know what
I'm saying?
Um, and I'm not defending him.
I think he does a lot of stupid shit and I
don't like, but all in all I would have voted
him a hundred times in a row, but Hillary
Clinton in a million and not even a close
shot.
So I'm interested in your insight into this.
Yeah, go ahead.
If she had won, I would've supported her as
my president just right.
So, okay.
So when you go back to the things that you
did, and again, you were working mostly within
the legal framework and stepping outside of
it, like you say, 5% Donald Trump's view on
economic policy is one of deregulation, right?
Taking away regulations.
Is your, is your sense that the way to deal
with the type of financial industry malfeasance
that you were around, is the solution less
regulation or more regulation?
I think it's the right regulation.
So I that most regulations are completely
ridiculous.
They, all they do is stifle growth.
They stifle competition and they don't accomplish
what they were meant to accomplish because
the people who wrote them.
What ends up happening is by time the regulation
acids, it got so watered down by lobbying
groups and by political interests and by PACS
that what I end up seeing is not a legitimate
solution to what it's trying to accomplish
because it's been hamstrung and there's all
this horse trading going on behind the scenes.
So I believe that the catalyst Mark is without
regulation, will completely run a mock because
that's the nature of the human beast.
They need to be regulated.
But that being said, the regulations that
are in place need to be of the magnitude that
dissuades any activity that would lead a girl
age, not having his or her interests mutually
aligned with the investor.
That's the biggest thing that happens.
All these situations where you have a situation
where we're basically from the beginning,
it's a bankrupt philosophy because the people
who are on one side, meaning the brokers,
traders, agents, whatever they are, and the
people whose money that they're managing,
that what's best for what is worse for the
other, right?
So you end up with churning.
I end up with people making misrepresentations.
Right now.
The hedge fund model was theoretically a step
in the right direction where you have these
two and 20 deals where, okay, well I'm only
gonna really make money if you make money
at 20% the problem with that is the two is
the 2% management corrupts the whole entire
thing because then what happens is, is you're
getting to the asset gathering game.
Well, I just gather enough assets gathered
through $3 billion.
That's 40 60 million a year just make before
I do anything.
But the problem with that is then the more
assets you got in that, the hardest to get
people to return on those assets, right?
You may go good for small amounts of money,
but it becomes difficult on large amounts.
So all these hedge funds got into these, these
two and 20 games.
And if you look at Warren Buffett's right,
you're much better off just buying the fricking,
uh, the, the, the index because at the end
of the day, all that is two things and the
two kills you every time unless it's an extraordinarily
lucrative bun.
And those are few and far between.
And be the other side of the equation is that
they have to then justify activity.
Okay, if I'm giving you my money, then they
start to have to churn and trade to show someone,
you know, I'm doing something with your money.
So there's engaging activity that creates
commissions and I think the smartest money
is buy and hold for the longterm.
And you're much better off just buying an
index than anything else
back because this is super interesting.
So you and I are exactly on the same page
that there is a lack of a fiduciary duty that
financial professionals have to the investor,
which creates misaligned incentives the way
that you're talking about now.
What's interesting to me about that is you
said economically you like what Donald Trump
is doing, but Donald Trump is against putting
in place some kind of a fiduciary responsibility
for the financial industry like that, that
exists with lawyers and uh, with, um, for
example, real estate professionals.
So is that an area where you disagree with
Donald Trump?
Well, the question you're asking was the way
it was that, you know, like re economically,
now you're talking about regulation, they're
two different things.
I agree that I think that you can't argue
with success.
Okay.
Whatever Donald Trump has done.
And also remember this, we fed Obama that
very much of where an economy is during a
president's first term has to do with his
predecessor that came before him.
So it's not all Donald Trump's, um, you know,
success here.
Some of it, and I, and I, again, I'm, I, I
skew Republican, right?
But you have to give Obama some credit as
well.
Okay.
For delivering the economy, even though it
was anemic compared to what it is right now,
it's always a letting the economy lag.
Let's explore that in a little bit of detail.
Yeah, I mean the lag time, the economic theory
is
definitely a real thing.
But like for example, if we just look at stock
market, which I think for a lot of people
the stock market is not hugely relevant to
their lives
indicator.
The stock market.
That's a forward indicator to me.
Not only a lagging indicator.
So what's interesting about that is if you
look at Obama's first three years in Trump's
first three years, Obama's first three years
of the stock market outperformed Trump's.
How do we interpret that?
I don't look, the stock market is a bogus
indicator for, okay, got it.
What do you look at?
It's not cheap money.
The price interest.
It's just like I got a, you can't even look
at that as the health of the economy.
I look at more GDP, things like that, you
know, growth, unemployment rates report, it's
in minority groups.
I think those are the more important things
to real wage increases.
So I think those are far more telling signs
for the economy than the stock market.
And what do you think is the lag time, in
other words, for how many months during president
number two do we attribute the economy to
the person that came before them, so to speak?
Well, I think it is to remember there's two
factors involved here, right?
There's the policies and then there's the
mindset, right?
So in other words, you have a president that's
a cheerleader for business.
It's a church that that promotes business.
It creates confidence in people.
So people start to spend more, they believe
things will loosen up and get better.
So all of a sudden you have this a consequence
for from selling saying they gonna loosen
regulations, which makes people spend money,
which results in growth versus when people
think that laws are gonna change, tax is going
to go up and all of these things, people will
start to clamp their, their, their, their,
their financial belts tighter because of what
they believe to be the future being slower.
So this is immediate impact of just having
someone saying, here's what I'm going to do.
And it becomes almost a self fulfilling prophecy.
Doesn't that only apply though to like really
the the top of the economy because the average
person who's barely saving, well, let me,
let me get, let me just lay it out and I'll
give you time to respond.
The average person who is like, okay, what's
toilet paper costing right now?
What are, what are my, what's my food costing?
They're not really being influenced by possible
future changes to the tax law.
Right.
I mean that doesn't seem to make any sense.
I disagree with that really.
I think that's the Elizabeth Warren may when
she said, Oh well the crumbs that on Nancy
polos and got the crumbs.
When you give someone a tax break and they
get back a check for a thousand or $1,500
that's a lot of money for the average family.
That's a lot of money.
And also in addition, all those people have
credit cards.
In other words, so much of it is consumer
confidence, so it all comes, remember the
country reflects the collective will of all
the people within the country.
It's not just the Machiavellian people at
the top.
You know, there's people who are the Pittsburgh
consumer based economy.
We're not a manufacturing based economy.
Most of our economy is based on consumer spending
in financial products.
These are what's being a manufacturing base.
Well, Trump's trying to bring that back, but
come on.
I mean that's not what we do.
It's not like the 18 hundreds anymore.
Massive amount of economic growth year is
based on consumer spending and financial instruments
that are all focused on wall street.
That's just the bottom line.
We're where I'm concerned and you know, I,
I mean my, my, my view is clear, but I don't,
I'm not a black white person on this.
In other words, I want to look in
looking at the details where I get, yeah,
no, no.
I know where I get concerned is, for example,
when they did the tax reform in 2017 people
started seeing a little bit more money in
their paychecks, but part of that was not
really a tax cut.
It was that the withholding tables were changed.
So during the year people had a little bit
more money and at the end of the year they
got a smaller refund and their effective tax
rate was basically the same.
Some people a little more, some people a little
less.
If your additional spending is based on a
misunderstanding of your tax rate, isn't that
bad in the longterm?
I disagree with you and I, that's not, I think
what you just said is incorrect really.
I don't have the actual who's in front of
me.
Yeah.
I think that's incorrect by the effective
tax rates go down, not for everybody but for
massive amount of people tax rates.
They'd go down.
The things I did in life just to say I think
there are certain things that really would
want unfair.
For instance, you're penalized heavily for
being in a state that has high state taxes.
California in New York where you can no longer
write your state deductions off against your
federal tax.
Right.
That was a disaster for me.
Also changing the, the methodology of how
you deduct interest on your home mortgage,
uh, changed drastically up to a certain so
that, so like there was things I didn't like
about the tax cut, but clearly more money
did effectively get put into the pockets of
people and not just in a deferral basis.
It'll real basis.
Now if you want to show me numbers, uh, an
actual study that's independent, it says that
that's not what happened.
I'm open to open.
I didn't know we were going to talk about
this.
The studies do exist, but in any case it seems
like at least philosophically we were getting
a sense of where we are.
So
yeah, take an overarching point.
And my overarching point is, is that when
people think things are going to get better,
it makes things get better.
When people think things are going to get
worse, they stop spending and it makes things
worse.
Very.
The great part of economics is self fulfilling
prophecies.
And it goes back to the old thing from Eklund
role.
It's only the fear is fear itself.
Fear is paralyzing.
Okay?
Fear stops you from spending.
It stops people from buying on their credit
cards.
That's why George Bush like did, was not a
big fan of the son w right?
We said, yeah, if you don't go out and spend
a terrorist when, I mean like after nine 11
you know what I'm saying?
So anyway, my, I think what you're missing
here though is that when we talk about economic
growth, you brought up a very valid point
about the cost of toilet paper and toothpaste
or whatever it might be, the cost of going
out for dinner.
When we talk about economic growth being a
robust 4% right.
Does that, if you take that to the individual
level, does that really matter to someone?
Like why should it matter?
Cause if someone's making a, hold on one second,
I have to interject.
4% doesn't exist.
Trump talked about 4% but if we want to talk
real numbers, we just got the 2019 report.
It was 2.9
I'm not making no, no, no, no, no.
I'm making a philosophical.
Okay, fair enough.
I'm talking anywhere in the world and we talk
about economic growth in general being 3%
of them, 5% it doesn't matter what the number
is.
What I'm saying is, is incrementally so the
individual, if your paycheck goes up and down,
you've been stressed about it, 3% or 2% does
it really impact your life that much?
If you make 50,001 year and 49,000 X is going
to radically alter your existence, no, you're
still gonna buy toilet paper.
You're still gonna buy toothpaste.
So these little things of like these little
3% growth is so robust.
I mean, at the end of the day, so much of
this is about perception.
It's about the how much credit is available
for people.
That to me is what really drives so much of
economic growth.
And I think that regulations, well, regulations
are important that do I believe in deregulation.
I still believe in financial regulation.
In other words, I think in the financial world
it needs to be stringent regulation to avoid
the sort of things that happened back in 2007
that was a joke.
And a disaster and it was an eyesore coming
way before it happened.
I did because I was in the mortgage industry
and I had been on wall street and I knew there
was a disconnect between what people were
saying in reality I watched it happen and
um, all I'm saying is that when you're passing
rules, I think a lot of the laws that are
on the books that Trump did repeal will, will
actually really beneficial to economic growth.
But I'm not talking about wall street regulation.
That's a different animal.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
I mean what's interesting is, and I know you've
got to go in a second.
What's interesting is we have our analysis
of the growth being a self fulfilling prophecy
or contraction being a self fulfilling prophecy
is basically the same.
Where I go further than I think you go is
that when it is not based on a strong and
real foundation, it ultimately leads to these
boom and bust cycles where yes, if the perception
is positive, you'll get the spending in the
short term.
But if it's not built on a strong foundation,
it will ultimately collapse the way we saw,
for example, with the mortgage crisis where
the perception was properties are going to
be worth more.
The banks were willing to lend.
Credit was available, like you said, but it
was a weak foundation and so it imploded.
Well that that imploded for a number of reasons.
Starting with the biggest one being fraud,
fraud, massive wholesale fraud at standard
and boards and booties.
That's where it had gone and that's what really
that was what allowed it to happen was a complete
breakdown of the system that allowed companies
like Goldman Sachs at all.
Okay.
They have pieces of stamp triple a that should
have never been stamped AAA and that's what
allowed all of this to happen and the result
was backed up in Iceland and Greece and whatnot.
Separate issue.
Well, here's my take just to close this whole
thing up because I got to go in a minute.
Oh, I don't think we're far off in all views,
but I think there's a far greater issue here
and that is the fiscal deficit.
All right.
That's very much disagree.
I think we definitely disagree on that one.
So I am very concerned.
Okay.
I deeply am concerned about the size of the
deficit and the continually kicking the can
down the road.
And you know, at a certain point you gotta
pay the Piper.
I don't know how you could reach, that's not
a problem.
But I'd love to hear, how would you say it's
not a problem?
Well, it's a, it's a bigger conversation,
but of course number one, you have to look
at the size of the deficit relative to GDP
growth.
Because if the economy keeps expanding, you
can have a larger number of dollars of deficit,
but it's roughly the same percentage.
So that's one thing that's important to think
about.
But if you check out modern monetary theorists,
I believe that they make very strong points
about deficits for economically stimulative.
Government spending are not bad deficits for
bad government spending, like tax cuts for
the rich where the money gets stuffed into
a bank account that is not quite so good.
So we, we probably disagree philosophically
there.
Well, no, it's just no, those terrorists,
they, you know what they are, they're theorists.
Okay.
Well I know we all in the real world of business,
in the real world of life, you cannot be borrowing
and borrowing and borrowing and not producing.
You can't keep consuming and consuming and
dumping money into, into guns and military
and all this stuff.
You cannot allow the government to just keep
printing money.
It ain't gonna work forever and that much.
I know I'm right about when that day comes.
Who knows?
But yeah, keep balling.
Cause we do not live in fantasy land.
So I know most people they work at probably
at Goldman Sachs and the other companies and
that's why they say what they say because
it's in their interest to say that the think
tank and all these people, they're there,
they're bought and PayPal for in the real
world.
You just, what the real world.
You cannot borrow forever and borrow and borrow
and keep borrowing.
It's impossible.
A government is not a household.
But I think that that's where we can, uh,
we will agree to pause the conversation.
I know you've got to go.
Jordan Belfort.
Don't miss his book, the Wolf of wall street.
Also, you can check out the movie, but by
the way, my podcast.
Yes, I follow you.
I follow Jordan
Instagram.
He has awesome sales techniques and all sorts
of cool stuff.
Jordan, I really appreciate your time.
All right.
Thank you.